We talked before about different data types
in particular this uint8 or unsigned integer
eight bit quantity. Let’s just have a little
bit of a look at numeric values and I am going
to do a really trivial example here.
I am going to create a variable called A which
is equal to 100, variable called B which is
equal to 200. You can do some really simple
arithmetic and you can work out what the answers
are going to be.
A plus B is 300. A minus B is -100. A divided
by B is equal to 0.5, all exactly as we would
expect. These numeric quantities within MATLAB
are double precision numbers.
Let’s remove these variables from the workspace.
They are all gone, and I am going to create
variables now of uint8 type. So this variable
A; we can see it is of the uint8 type and
it has got a value of 100 just like before,
but the type is different. We create the variable
B, it has got a value of 200 and it is of
the uint8 type. So now let’s do some arithmetic.
Lets add A and B together. It has got a value
of 255.
Subtract them and we see that the value is
0. Now let’s do a division. So these answers
are a little bit surprising and the reason
for this is that the unsigned integer eight
bit numbers have got a very limited dynamic
range.
So the results that we see here on our screen
make perfect sense. I add the two numbers
together and although the results should be
300, the maximum possible value that it can
have as a uint8 type is 255 and that is what
MATLAB has set it to.
Similarly, the smallest possible value it
can have is 0, so although the correct result
was -100, MATLAB has set the answer to 0.
Well we call it clipping. So the results have
been clipped. They can not go below 0 and
they cannot go above 255.
The division result is also a little bit surprising.
What has happened here is that A divided by
B, the result is 0.5 and MATLAB has rounded
that up to the value of 1. In many programming
languages, if I divide a small integer by
a larger integer the result will be 0. MATLAB
has done a rounding operation and given a
value of 1.
In terms of the actual computer hardware,
the uint8 type is stored in a single byte
of the computer’s memory. The smallest value
is when all of the eight bits have got a value
of 0, equivalent to a decimal value of 0.
And the largest value is when all of the bits
have got a value of 1, which is the equivalent
to the decimal value of 255.
For an arbitrary n bit integer, the maximum
value is 2n -1. MATLAB supports a number of
additional unsigned integer types; it supports
uint16 which has got 16 bits, and uint32 which
has got 32 bits, and these are able to represent
numbers with much larger maximum values.
Now we have displayed this image before and
as previously discussed, the pixels in this
image are of a type unsigned integer. Click
around and here we have the integer values
of the pixels. The brightest one will be 255;
the smallest one will be 0.
Now there is another way that we can represent
the pixels in an image and I am going to create
a new variable, I am going to call it imd,
image double. And what we are going to do
is read the image again, but into a different
variable this time. We are going to pass the
option double, and what this will do is convert
all of the pixels into double precision numbers,
instead of unsigned integer numbers.
Now let’s display this new image and I will
create a new figure. And I will display my
new image in this new figure. Now we see it
looks exactly the same as the other one, but
if I click around on the pixel values here
we will see that they are floating point numbers
now. And in this convention, 0 represents
black and 1 represents white. So this is a
reasonably bright number; in the dark of this
door way, the pixel values are only 0.03.
So this is another way of representing an
image, each pixel, each element in this matrix
is a double precision number. So we have a
lot of precision with each of the pixel values
in this representation of the image. The disadvantage
is that such an image requires much, much,
more memory.
The double precision numbers occupy eight
bytes of storage; the uint8 occupies only
one byte of storage, so this image on the
right-hand side occupies eight times more
memory than the image on the left. And we
can see that quite easily, using the about
function; tell me about the variable im. We
can see it occupies 1.1 megabytes of memory
in the computer. Let’s have a look at the
other image and you can see that it occupies
8.7 megabytes.
But sometimes there are advantages in having
the pixels represented by double precision
numbers.
In terms of the actual computer hardware,
the double precision number is organised in
memory like this. It occupies 8 bytes of computer
memory or a total of 64 bits.
And the first bit is the sign bit and that
has got a 0 for a positive number, 1 for a
negative number. That is followed by 11 exponent
bits and 52 fraction bits and I’ll talk
about those in a moment.
This particular layout is defined by the IEEE
754 standard, so floating point numbers on
almost all computers today are represented
in this particular fashion.
Now if we denote the fraction part by F and
the exponent part by E, the actual value that
is represented is Fx2E. So the E is the exponent
part and F is what we call the fraction part—sometimes
also called the mantissa.
Now, the exponent has got a range of -1022
to 1021. If we do the conversion from binary
into decimal, we see that this gives us a
range of this multiplication factor which
goes from 10-308, to almost 10307. So this
kind of number has got an enormous dynamic
range. Now the exponent is represented by 11 bits
that has got 2048 possible different values.
Four of those values are reserved, they are
special and one of them is used to represent
an infinite number, another is used to represent
a negative infinite number. One is used to
represent what is called not a number, so
that is something that is numerically invalid.
And another value is used to represent the
precise value of zero.
The fraction is organised so that it is always
in the range from 0.5 to 1. So the most significant
bit in a fraction represents 2-2 or 1/4.
The least significant bit has got an equivalent
value of about 10-16, so that means that this
double precision representation has got effectively
16 significant digits. So a lot of numeric
precision and a very, very, large dynamic
range; that is the advantage of this double
precision floating point representation of
numbers within a computer.
Now there’s some limits to the precision
and if we consider a number like this, 0.1,
that is a tenth in decimal, it doesn’t have
a precise representation as a binary fraction.
It is a repeating fraction in binary, so we
can’t represent it precisely.
An example of this is, for instance, I want
to look at the decimal value 90.1. And I tell
MATLAB to display this in its long format,
so that is showing a lot of decimal digits
and what we see is that 90.1 is actually represented
internally by 90.09999... and the last digit
is shown as 4. So it is wrong in the seventeenth
significant digit, but as we just talked about
a moment ago, double precision guarantees
you around sixteen significant figures, so
this is to be expected.
So, to recap the numeric ranges of these different
representations that we use for pixels.
We can represent pixels as either unsigned
eight bit integers which would occupy a single
byte of computer memory each, and they have
a numeric range of 0 and 255. Or we can represent
them as double precision floating point numbers—they
occupy eight bytes of computer storage each.
And we typically map pixel intensities into
the range 0 to 1, 0 being dark, 1 being bright.
There are also some difficulties when we use
integer arithmetic. One of the problems is
saturation, so if the result of our arithmetic
operation exceeds the maximum possible value
for that representation, it is clipped or
limited to the maximum possible value for
the representation.
So in this case, the result of the arithmetic
should be 300. But it is clipped to 255, which
is the maximum possible value of a uint8 type.
Another problem is quantisation, so if we
look at these two divisions—49 divided by
100 gives a result of 0—it is effectively
rounded down to 0, whereas
50 divided by 100 is rounded up to 1.